the sleigh bells are ringing and Santa
just stopped by to drop off our presents
we're gonna open them later and trust me
you don't want to miss it we have a
fun-filled hour for you answering your
questions posted on our Facebook page so
is everybody ready yes grab your eggnog
let's go just really had some before the
show
indeed okay so this is a good one we're
gonna start off with a bang from Jamie D
what is your go-to Christmas gift when
you don't really want to buy a gift Greg
for someone that you know that you have
to get them something anyway that's good
I actually just kind of go down into the
basement rummage around if there's
something in there I have a lot of
interesting artifacts from the past
things that I've taken from museums
resent this whole eggnog thing some of
us are lactose intolerant we can't enjoy
eggnog yeah we noticed yes I know but
I'm tired of eggnog privilege yes I'm so
sorry we make him drink eggnog in a
little closet by himself disgusting okay
so Dana what's you're very good at gifts
you've been very smart I love I love to
be I like to figure out like the perfect
gift for someone but for this particular
question I wine is always good okay I
like to if it's um if the person is of
age but then this year so I went over to
the feed store over at in Brooklyn that
Lauren Bush lauren hasn't they have all
sorts of different products have they're
started with bags they have now have
little animals like stuffed animals and
candles things like that and if you buy
one of their products it corresponds
with however many meals that pres that
gift would buy for somebody else so I I
kind of like that one this year I that's
a very good I understand what you said
just said what is it usable it's like a
so if you buy a gift and it's like so
basically what it is you make a bag
right by the stores profits going and
you help people by how much profit how
much do they give away like up one
percent most oh really that's good all
right Greg so try to slow my roll here
Christmas Yuletide situation okay Jesse
and what would you do or like for
somebody you know you have to get a gift
you really know what to get I'm a big
regifter so if someone gives me
something deep table I will then pass
that off as something I bought for them
but you have to make sure you take off
the name tag in the note because I'm
giving gifts to people you know hello
thing Merry Christmas and it goes you
know Merry Christmas
Frank merry crits not that person how
it's happened once or twice also I like
wine and here's why no one knows how
much the wine cost so it could be at
like a thirteen dollar bottle of wine
but if you wrap it up in a nice little
package know there's a the rege if did
bottle of wine know what you know what
the thing is your office you haven't
written a book yet because that's the
old to me gifts like a stack of books
that's why I should you yes it's a
whenever I you don't I just grab a book
in lieu of that I'm gonna do a signed
headshot he's the kind of guy that gives
the signed headshot when it hasn't been
requested part of it right who doesn't
want to sign that job we're all just do
that leave an autograph on like
airplanes and stuff for people it's
amazing really okay this is hilarious
but okay you answer this one but the
next one is from Kimberly G which wasn't
me but okay it wasn't you know look
Kimberly G is the next question but it
wasn't me that put this question in okay
so what's your gonna guess that's a
coincidence you gave me I mean money is
the obvious answer I think you just give
people money but so there first of all
yeah I guess there's somebody you don't
really know $1.00 absolutely I mean I
you know what I like is gift cards but
then I read in the newspaper nobody you
know they don't use that so then look
what the companies just forget get tons
of money from people who don't use gift
cards because they end up in like your
kitchen drawer and they say oh yeah we
got this gift card and then it sometimes
it expires well but Jesse really loves
gift cards from self riscos if I
actually have to go shopping and
rear I don't I mean I'll go like to a
mall for fun but I don't like to go
shopping but if I have to go shopping
and I said oh somebody I don't know and
I somehow have to give them the gift
which is crazy anyway I mean like you
know what's happened to me this
Christmas know what being in New York
all the time that's happened to me now a
couple Christmas because I've been here
at Christmastime is I have to give the
doorman my head of course and you have
to give the people who work in the hotel
and the people at the restaurants who
see you regularly and pretty singing
like wow this is expense tell me about
it my masseuse my footman
my sous-chef not just my Shepherd my
sous-chef your footman is what I'm
really concerned it's interesting by
foot and we go way back but I will get
into it here yes he knows a lot of dirty
secrets sad to say so do i and I'll
never quite be the same let me finish my
faux yes there's more to money and gift
cards I always think plants like
poinsettias or whatever that's a
commitment that we yeah be quick if
you're going by like they have them in
the supermarket these yes they have them
on set you could grab one and then give
it to one of your people that you don't
know that well complaining cuz yes to
tip his doorman not only there it's not
one doorman if they're like oh you have
a great idea about give gift cards they
should be useful like a gift card that's
like $100 for toilet paper you're gonna
use that you're gonna have it in your
you could make it for Amazon and you can
actually buy then you forget about it
you know forget about TP okay that's
moving on to the rest of my awesome
question from Kimberly G do you have a
childhood family Christmas tradition
that you've carried into your adult life
if you have what is it tell us now Dana
well I guess it's attending Christmas
Eve service I always like that like the
candle light wine except for I like to
go at 7:00 p.m. no that's bad by ADA
yeah
that means I'll wake up sooner and get
it over with not over won't be there
sooner yes I've done the opposite I've
broken all the traditions because I was
forced to go to church on Christmas and
now because I can decide myself because
I'm a man I don't go to church anymore
on Christmas that's the time you don't
want to go to church the mom texts other
Sunday I think you should recall that
answer thank you on with want agrees now
I'm actually worried about it's amateur
hour Church exactly I'm telling I go to
church every Sunday so it's not a matter
I'm just telling you for that service
it's like it's like this most special
day besides Easter I think Easter is the
high okay well anyway I think so they're
two things that happen one is ornaments
on the tree that you know my parents and
the lease is my wife's parents both
handed down ornaments and we have now
handed down ornaments like my son Rafi
he just got a house and he has a bay
window with a tree and he has now
ornaments that came from us alright
let's do a couple of these quicker shall
we from susan w what is your favorite
Christmas Carol Greg I hate Christmas
carols as you know passing from Greg
tradition my tradition is might look I
go around the neighborhood and I see who
has the most Christmas lights and I
steal their ladder my favorite Christmas
Carol Carol Channing I like Carol Grady
I think walking in a winter wonderland
is it a good one I get that stuck in my
head a lot ok that's a good one I like
it what about hark hark the angels
saying is that that one The Herald the
herald angel that's what I said he's
Jesse's like Christmas fail ok Greg do
you have a Christmas carol I think we
already came to me I would
take Carol Brady from the Brady Bunch
all right one one answer well but I
don't think there's much question you
know I'll be home for Christmas
Oh fantastic I like that so my daughter
got a new car they got a new car
Christmas No so your son gets a house
your daughter is doing great
so license tag reads hark hmm I said why
is that that your vanity plates say hark
because her last name is Harold that's
very cute mine's h2o s okay Jesse there
you go you don't have a personalized
license plate if you do that's so water
because they can like track what car
you're in and I want to keep a low
profile Jesse you'll love this question
it involves your very special
relationship if you could give the
president a gift what would it be
[Laughter]
hmm Dana I Jasper calendar oh my god a
good one get Greg dragonboat he's track
of the days Oh obviously I give him a
map of Kenya did you mean Trump yes it's
a joke just remember used to President
Obama would give it to Hillary Clinton
if she was president and also chomp I
think so any case of Diet Coke I would I
would give him a lump of coal
yeah why she's making cold radio so much
cheaper net for the two lumps two lumps
its can I put it in this coffee pot okay
she likes it black